now 607 so tomorrow marks the beginning
of may and it's a time to celebrate
asian pacific american heritage month
yeah discovery children's museum is
celebrating all month long with
some really cool performances and
activities for kids we have hector mejia
live downtown with a preview hey hector
let's get right to it discovery
children's museum here
with a lot of hands-on activities for
the children and joining us live we have
sam nelson
with the museum good morning to you good
morning so what do we have here
so we have lots of different crafts
celebrating asian pacific
american heritage month which places are
we highlighting for the entire month
so for the month of may we'll be doing
five different countries china
japan thailand hawaii and samoa
samoa and tell us about the performances
you know
las vegas being considered the ninth
island hawaii being highlighted here we
also have some performances
definitely so this is gary and shel dean
members of the discovery family
performing
all right so let's listen in for just a
little bit
so that is just one of several
performances on the schedule
what's first though is it samoa samoa is
first up this saturday we'll be doing a
workshop and artist workshop this
saturday
all right well we're going to end again
with a beautiful music going on right
now this beautiful performance
for now reporting live hector mejia 8
news now back to you guys
hector thank you very much the music
sounds great yes by the way we're aware
hawaii is not a country for the record
we know it's a state yes fyi in our
country